this is working
this video is brought to you by motion
array which i'll tell you more about
later
in this video i along with my good
friend casey neistat built the cheapest
most functional shitty camera rig the
world has ever seen
[Music]
and then we test it so good before
getting started if you haven't already
please hit that subscribe button and
turn your notifications below on and
then comment and let me know when you
have done so okay cool so there's this
instagram page called shitty rigs
[Music]
which is a great showcase of the phrase
anything for the shot just how far
filmmakers will go to capture a moment
my goal in this video is to see how far
i can go with as little money as
possible and in turn building the
shittiest most functional
cheapest
shitty
great underwater action camera available
possible rig
ever
okay first things first is to find the
cheapest camera available in my
proximity that's at least 1080p hd so
that's what i'm going to do right now on
facebook marketplace
[Music]
there is so much [ __ ] on here i spent
about an hour scouring facebook
marketplace looking for an available
camera until i found this camcorder for
only 250 rand which is 17
and a very much needed fisheye lens for
270 round which is 18 us dollars
[Music]
i'm on my way to come and get the camera
[Music]
cool back to the studio
okay i already know this but i just
wanted to show the camera
the battery is fully charged and
it came with a memory card
now to turn this camera into an
underwater action cam
first i went to my local hardware store
to get a bunch of pvc pipes and then to
my friend graham who cut this plexi
glass into a perfect circle
never give the chalice wasn't gifted
balance hell [ __ ] steady with my hands
you can see it in the callus okay just
to keep you in the loop i've attached
this pipe
to lengthen this thing so that the
camera can fit in here and then i
attached
this thing
so that this thing
can close on there and i'm going to seal
it
see them speaking fallacy i've seen them
very talents behind the curtains it's a
fantasy too they call it magic i don't a
beauty pageant of source i could imagine
of course
now we're gonna look for any bubbles if
bubbles come out of here well then we
are [ __ ]
looking good looking good
really good
[Music]
cool now to test it
yo
hey dan what's up
you want to go surfing
yeah yes
you're keen
very much
do you have a mount for this i've got
something so much better that's why you
get
the gopro footage
because i want to get i need to get good
water footage but you can't hold it up
right
i made
the greatest
shittiest
but functional underwater housing the
trouble is the lens is going to be too
narrow to do for surfing don't you worry
about that
it's like an old
hip-hop video
[Music]
the trouble is how do we waterproof it
i don't trust
what
that's my line oh
but isn't the waterproof line in my line
it doesn't matter okay velcro plexiglas
[Music]
what happens if your big wave takes you
stuff some foam in there damn
of course i thought of that
[Laughter]
liam found
[Music]
[Laughter]
okay fun
yeah you want to cut back on that rattle
[Music]
how do you know if it's rolling
okay so you press roll
this is the one difference between a
gopro and this right okay so you gotta
have more than one but yeah yeah you
gotta press roll okay prior
basically failure proof
exactly that's what i'm thinking
yeah i'd trust my life for this
is it rolling now do you think yeah i
guess there's no way to
know okay
let's go
see in the syrup
[Music]
[Music]
look at it
okay dry as a bone wow
let's see the footage
dude it looks so good
you know what it is it has style
all new cameras look the same they're
clean they're polished this looks like
something
i think i missed your best wave you did
back to the studio
cool here's the edit from the shitty
[ __ ]
cool stylish camera rig
[Music]
you ready
ready
[Music]
that looks sick
so [ __ ] sick
oh it wasn't raining
cool drop a comment below and let me
know what you thought of this camera rig
here's my two cents it was a hell of a
lot of work but i love making videos and
making challenging videos like this
really makes me appreciate
the smaller action cameras
like these and uh yeah i'd advise
probably just
you know
yeah otherwise if you enjoyed this video
please click the subscribe button and
don't forget to turn your notifications
back on
all right if you're familiar with my
videos you'll know that i use a ton of
animation to contextualize the story
especially when i don't have the footage
to do so and for all of these i use
motion array motion array is super
simple to use it's the quickest way to
make your content look amazing you can
go from good to great in a ridiculously
short amount of time it's really easy
you can download things in a second or
you can install plugins and extensions
for premiere after effects and photoshop
and get assets even faster you can try
it for free you won't get access to
everything of course but you'll get
hundreds of free assets click on the
link in my description now to up your
story time by joining motion arrays over
700 000 premium quality templates assets
stock videos and music also by clicking
the link in my description you get 50
off your annual subscription so yeah
sign up today other than that don't
forget you're awesome bruh and i'll see
you next week
[Music]
you